As we go ahead and start applying rules of inferences to sentences in
a knowledge base. We'll find it convenient to rewrite the sentences in
a knowledge base. And sometimes it will be very useful to rewrite these
sentences in the knowledge base in a manner that eliminates the implications in
a sentence. And this is how we can eliminate the implication. If a implies b,
than we can rewrite it as not a or b. We know this because the truth
value of a implies b is exactly the same as your truth value of not a or
b. We can take an example here. Supposing that we are given feathers imply bird.
Then we can rewrite this as not feathers or bird. And intuitively,
you can see the truth value of this. It is either the animal does not have
feathers or, it is a bird. In a little bit, we will see that this is
a important rewrite rule in doing certain kinds of logical proofs.